hi everyone I'm Mark thanks very much
for watching this video this is Joint
work with Marco Cresson Leslie Goldberg
and kitty Meeks and as you see in the
title this will be about counting sub
graphs and somewhere dense graphs
let me start by introducing the most
important problems we will be
considering in this work
um I'll start with the homomorphism
problem so here we are giving us input
to graphs H and G and we are interested
in the number of homomorphisms from H to
G just to recall the definition of
homomorphism from H to G is the mapping
from the vertices of H to the vertices
of G that is Edge preserving so whenever
there is an edge in h then the image of
this Edge must also be an hng but the
mapping itself is not necessarily
injective so two vertices of H might be
mapped to the same vertex of G
the next problem we will be studying is
the counting subgraph problem the input
is the same but now we would like to
count the copies of H and G that is the
number of subgraphs of G that are
isomorphic to H like this one here note
they are Intermediate Education between
the vertices of the subgraph so it's not
an induced subgraph and indeed we are
also interested in counting the number
of induced subgraphs
um like this one
um we are interested in the complexity
of all three of those problems but we
will always assume that the pattern is
much smaller than the host graph and we
model this by parameterizing those
problems by the size of the pattern so
let me do this like that
and now the more formal question we are
interested to answer in this work is
okay under which circumstances are those
problems fixed payment attractable that
is solvable in time F of the pattern
times the polynomial in the size of the
host and F might be any computable
function the idea here is that assuming
the pattern is significantly smaller
than the host then even a say super
polynomial overhead in the size of the
pattern might still yield an efficient
algorithm as long as we are polynomial
in the size of the host
if you take a look at those problems in
this generality it is very unsurprising
that the answer is uh no in the very
general case all of those three problems
are hard because we could choose for H
for the pattern the complete graph of K
vertices and then it's very easy to show
that all three problems are equivalent
to the problem of counting K clicks and
this problem is the canonical complete
problem for the complexity class sharp
W1 you can think of sharp W1 as the
parameterized counting equivalent of NP
so under some famous assumptions such as
eth problems that are hard for Sharp W1
are not fixed parameter directable
now since those problems are hard in
general we ask first okay for which
patterns can we do better so can we
restrict the patterns in such a way that
we get fixed permit.rectable instances
and this is uh formally done by
equipping uh all problems with a class
of allowed patterns note this glass is
part of the problem definition and not
part of the input
um the input of the problem is now
restricted uh in the sense that the
pattern must be in the class of allowed
patterns and then we can refine our
question and ask for which classes of
patterns those problems are fixed permit
attractable and whether we can prove
sharp W1 hardness for all other patterns
and indeed in the beginning of
parameterized complexity Theory
answering those questions so those three
questions was kind of one of the major
goals and we are now in the um a very
fortunate situation that this question
here is already completely answered so
for homomorphisms dymo and Johnson
showed that um the problem is the
experiment attractable if and only if
the class of allowed patterns has
bounded tree with I won't Define tree
within this talk or just think of it as
a measure how Tweed like a graph is
and a bounded tree with means that there
is a constant such that the three width
of every class every graph in the class
is bounded by that constant and whenever
the tree with is unbounded they proved
sharp W1 hardness and this is really a
full and clear-cut complexity dichotomy
so we are fpt if the tree with responded
and in all other cases we are sharp W1
Hertz so there are no intermediate
complexities for this problem or for
this family of problems
a similar dichotomy was proved for
counting subgraphs here the Criterion is
not retrievous but the Criterion is the
matching number so more precisely the
problem was shown to be fpt even
polynomial time solvable if the class
overall patterns has bounded matching
number here the matching number is the
size of a maximum matching in a graph
again in all other cases the problem was
shown to be sharp W1 Hood
finally for induced subgraphs um we only
get fixed parameter tractability
um if the class of allowed patterns is
finite which is kind of the trivial case
because if this glass is finite then
there is a constant upper bound on the
size of any pattern we are allowed to
get as an input and this means even the
Brute Force algorithm runs in polynomial
time and this is what I mean by um only
the trivial cases are um fixed payment
attractable
um yeah because uh Chantilly and Via
proved that whenever the class of
allowed patterns is infinite the problem
is sharp W1 Hut
now those three theorems completely
answer the question about the complexity
of these problems but it's
um still kind of bad news because
especially in case of induced subgraphs
it basically states that all interesting
cases are hard
so we can ask can we do more and indeed
in this work we would like to restrict
the pattern and the host graph now it
comes to no surprise that we model this
uh restricting the hosts in a similar
way so we um equip the problem
definition also with the class of a lot
of toasts and we restrict the inputs in
such a way that now the pattern must be
in the class of law patterns and the
host must be in the class of lot hosts
and we ask for which classes of allowed
patterns into loud hosts are those
problems with experiment attractable and
also we ask can we prove sharp W1
hardness for all other cases
and here the bad news is that we cannot
do that anymore so in control in
contrast to the case where we only
restrict the patterns now if we restrict
the patterns and the hosts there is no
fpt versus sharp W1 heart dichotomy
anymore assuming that fpt is not equal
to Sharp W1
so to continue the question about the
complexity of those problems we have to
um
add some restrictions to the class of
allowed patterns and allowed hosts and
um we started by considering the
monotone case so now we assume that both
the class of allowed hosts hosts and the
glass overload patterns are monotone
that is closed undertaking subgraphs
examples of
monotone classes include those for
example a planar graph if we take a
subgraph of a planar graph this is still
a planar graph so planar crafts a
monotone on the other hand those are
non-examples so those classes are not
monotone they are closed under vertex
removal but they are not closed under
Edge removal
okay
um now since we also restrict the host
classes it turns out that the notion of
nowhere density and somewhere density is
crucial to answer our questions about
the complexity of those problems
the notion of nowhere density was
introduced by digital Anderson's uh 11
years ago
and very roughly this notion generalizes
a bunch of other Notions of sparsity
that were around in the literature at
the time
um as one concrete example if we have a
class of graphs of bounded tree width
this class is also novems
and then in a line of research
um it was possible to prove a very
strong meta theorem for um model
checking problems from nowhere dense
graph classes so um uh very quickly I
won't go into details here but
um assuming you fix any first order
formula
and then evaluating this formula on the
graph can be solved in almost linear
time if this graph belongs to a nowhere
dense class of graphs
and this can be thought as like a kind
of a variation of cosell's theorem
and it's very strong because this now
applies to all of those examples
um since nowhere density generalizes all
of those Notions of sparsity
there is also a counting version of this
meta theorem which will be important
later in this video
um the one
um the one restriction is that the
um the counting version only works for a
fragment of FO formulas and again I
won't go into details here because it's
not important for the details of the
talk but very roughly the idea is that
the counting version only allows if only
um works if we don't allow Universal
quantifiers
then finally just to avoid any confusion
confusion somewhere dense just means not
no evidence
the original definition of nowhere
density uses uh something called shallow
minus but in this talk since we consider
monotone classes
um we use another characterization which
applies to monotone classes and which is
much easier what I'm about to show you
is known in this community for a long
time I think the first paper that made
it explicit was this paper on Super
Fitness by Outland artra
so we can Define over density as follows
you say that the monotone class of
graphs is nowhere dense if and only if
this is true this means for each
non-negative integer there exists a
graph such that the r subdivision of
this graph is not in the class here the
r subdivision means that I subdivide
each Edge precisely R times
and by negating this we get also a very
short definition of some valence classes
and indeed this definition will be used
in our hardness grooves
it states that okay a class of graphs a
monotone class of graphs are somewhere
dense if and only if there exists a
non-negative integer R such that for all
graphs the r subdivision of this graph
is in the class
so father seems quite abstract so let's
take a look at some examples for Norway
density
um planar graphs boundary degree graphs
and crafts of boundary tribals are
nowhere dense I actually use those
examples on the previous slide but now
let's take a look how we can actually
prove that using this definition uh
let's consider planar graphs okay if we
take any non-planar graph then any
subdivision of this graph is also
non-planar and this means that um this
if G is any non-planar graph the
subdivision is never in the class
regardless of what R is and this shows
that planar graphs are indeed no
evidence
a similar Witnesses for being overdens
can be found for graphs of boundary
degree and for graphs of bounded tree
with
for some riddance classes of graphs we
can take a look at the examples of the
generate graphs by better graphs and
graphs of high graph let's start with
bipartite graphs this is pretty easy if
you do if you take the subdivision of a
graph this graph is always fiber tight
so we can actually choose R to be one
and this shows that then the subdivision
of each graph is Piper Titan and spider
type graphs are somewhere names
for graphs of high growth we call the
girth is the length of a shorter cycle
and this means if we say for example the
growth has to be larger than eight we
can just subdivide each Edge two times
and then the shortest cycle will have
length nine
um and this generalizes to any constant
lower bound on the glass
okay so now I hope we all have some uh
intuition about nowhere density and
somewhere density let's go back to our
problems and see how this actually helps
so we call that in the monotone case we
now still ask okay can we prove an fpt
versus sharp W one heart dichotomy for
this problem a long structural
parameters of the class of allowed
patterns and the loud hosts
and recall also that we have seen this
meta theorem for existential F4 model
counting and um without going into
details those three problems here
actually just special cases of
existential fo model Counting and this
means that regardless what the class of
the patterns is if the class of hosts is
nowhere dense then the problems are
always fpt
so this case is completely solved and
hence our contributions focus on the
case where other class of uh allowed
toasts is somewhere dense and indeed on
a technical level uh our
our proofs will mostly focus on hardness
so on reductions
okay now let me finally State our main
contributions and let me start with the
homomorphism problem
um
recall that we assume for now that uh
both the class of allowed patterns and
the class of loud hosts are monotone
that is subgraph closed
now we call that the problem is fpt
whenever the class of law patterns has
boundary with
and whenever the class of allowed hosts
is nowhere dense and we can show that
this is optimal so in the monotone case
at least
um whenever none of those two criteria
are satisfied we always get Darkness for
Sharp W1
we prove a similar theorem for counting
subgraphs
um again we call that if the cluster
Fallout hosts is nowhere dense we get an
almost linear time algorithm but we have
also seen that if the class overload
patterns has bounded matching number we
are also fpt here this m of H is just
the size of Maximum matching and if the
class has bounded matching number this
constant in the exponent this will be a
constant in the exponent and so we will
be fpt
and again uh we prove that all other
cases are sharp W1 Hut
now this
is to be quite uh abstract and it's not
clear
um how useful monotone as the
Restriction is so let me actually
um spend one slide on a concrete problem
uh more precisely I would like to show
you the following result on the problem
of counting K matchings which is one of
the most important problems in
parameterized counting complexity
um as a consequence of our theorem for
counting subgraphs we get the following
so for every monotone class of graphs
the problem of counting K matchings in a
graph in this class is fixed parameter
tractable
if and only if the class is nowhere
dense assuming that sharp W1 is not
equal to fpt
in particular whenever we have a
monotone somewhere dense class of host
the problem of counting K matchings in
graphs in that class is sharp W1 hot
and this subsumes and strengthens uh
various interactibility research for
County K matchings uh in a kind of a
unified hardness research for example as
an immediate consequence of this Theory
we get that counting k-matchings and
bipartite graphs with one-sided degree
bounds is hard or that counting K
matchings in graphs of high growth as
such all that counting K matchings in
degenerate crosses hard and again you
can use any monotone somewhere dense
class of graphs you like and you
immediately get hardness of counting
k-matchings
now I
um also mentioned before that we only
assumed uh the condition of being
monotone in the beginning and indeed for
sub graphs we can do more uh we also can
completely classify uh this family of
problems uh for monotone hosts but for
hereditary patterns and now hereditary
just means we are closed under vertex
removal but not necessarily under Edge
removal anymore
the classification of has more cases so
here is the table from our paper I won't
go through any entry of this table but I
just want to make like one particular
application of this classification
assuming that our hereditary class of
graphs has unbounded in use matching
number and is just the induced matching
number and the class of hosts is
somewhere dense has founded click number
but unbounded by Creek number then
the problem is hard note that our fpd
cases CR also refined we also we also
are able to find out precisely in which
cases we are in polynomial time uh and
in which cases we have PT and this fptk
is a real fpt case so it cannot be
strengthened to polynomial time unless
under the assumptions failure finally we
also get almost tight uh or even tight
lower bounds under the eth for our heart
dismissals and since those uh like um
columns and rows are disjoint and
exhausted if it's really a full and
explicit classification of the
complexity of this problem
okay finally induced subgraphs
um let me immediately jump to the result
for hereditary classes
um and again our results are like
summarized in the following table uh we
have less cases than for sub graphs but
they are still exhaustive and disjoint
so again we obtain a complete and
explicit characterization of the
complexity of this problem in terms of
uh of structural properties of the class
of load patterns and the class of a loud
hosts
in the last five minutes I would like to
quickly
um sketch the most important idea of our
proofs and the proofs are actually
surprisingly simple so the ideas were
like
um uh were like not uh trivia uh at all
uh But like after having the ideas like
working them out that turned actually
out to be quite simple in particular
much more simple than existing hardness
proofs for counting can imagings for
example
I will also only focus on counting
subgraphs in the remainder of this video
um because this is just the most
interesting case
now if you have seen any paper on
perimeterized counting in the last five
years chances are very high that you
have seen this framework
um if we want to understand the
complexity of counting subgraphs
um what we can do is we can cast this
problem as a linear combination of
homomorphism counts more precisely it is
known that for each graph age
uh they are it is possible to express
the function that counts the copies of H
in an input graph as a finite linear
combination like that so this notion
here Sharp home from F to Star is just
the function that Maps an input to the
number of homomorphisms from F to this
input
the reason why we are interested in this
expression is what is called the
complexity monotonicity principle which
was independently discovered by Shannon
mangle in the setting of database Theory
and by corticarb indelent marks in uh
yeah the a more graph theoretical
setting and the theorem is as follows or
the framework is as follows it says okay
if all of the terms with a non-zero
coefficients are easy to compute then
the entire sum is easy to compute okay
and proving this easiness direction is
also very easy but the interesting case
is that the other directions also true
this states that if they at least if
there's at least one term in this
expression with a non-zero coefficient
that is hard then the entire sum is hard
and this can be used to prove that
subgraph counting problems are hard note
that this property is very special in
general if you have a linear combination
of counting problems the entire linear
combination can be easy although
individual terms can be hard for example
counting satisfying assignments plus
counting non-satisfying assignments is
easy although each each individual term
is hard
Now using this framework in our setting
uh
um was kind of difficult because we had
to overcome two challenges the first one
um is that for the hardness part here
which is the most important part uh in
our proofs
um this one only applies if the inputs
here if the class of inputs is closed
under graph tensors and unfortunately
some evidence graph classes are not
generally closed under graph tensors
um not even if they are monotone so we
have to somehow overcome this difficulty
and the second problem is that uh in the
general case of some weddings inputs we
don't even know how hard the
homomorphism problem is
however the Second Challenge can be
solved by relying on the techniques we
use to prove our homomorphism
classification and in particular we will
find out that we can use our
subdivisions of expander graphs for f
I won't go into the details here
um feel free to talk to me in the poster
session or any time as the conference
the very final part I would like to
quickly sketch how we dealt with this
problem here with the tensorization
um we call that we have this very cute
condition here to classify or to
describe somewhere then smaller tone
classes of graphs
and what we do is we introduce an edge
colored tensor product that works on a
subdivided and Edge colored graphs so I
will only Define it by a picture the
technical details are a bit cumbersome
to state but they are not hard so if you
have crafts like this so um if you
cannot see the colors the parallel edges
you have always the same colors and
except for that all of the edge colors
are pairwise distinct and then if we
tends or two graphs with those kind of
colorings we split the vertices uh if
and only if the second graph here has
the vertices Split For example splitting
those vertices and those vertices here
yields that in this graph those vertices
like those two and this one is split I
know this is a proof by picture but this
picture actually encapsulates precisely
the important idea we need it
and then we actually are able to show
that any monotone somewhere dense class
of graphs is closed under this notion of
tensors and for this we use this
classification using subdivisions
okay and with uh this um modified
version of a graph tensor we are able to
prove that complexity monotonicity still
applies and in particular it applies to
any monotone somewhere dense class of
graphs
okay now in the last minute let me very
quickly uh um discuss some obvious open
problems so the first one is
um we now okay for most of our problems
we now solved it for hereditary patterns
and monotone hosts but can we do it for
hereditary patterns and for hereditary
hosts so both cases are hereditary there
might be a dichotomy for that I think
there is one
also if uh we stick to the realm of
monotone hosts we might ask whether we
get a dichotomy for all kinds of
patterns and here I'm quite sure that
the answer is yes but it will be quite
difficult to state so I'm not sure if
it's easy to find an explicit one
because it will rely on the Forbidden
subgraphs of G but I still think there
is one
and finally
um since we still most of our results
are hardness results we can now ask okay
can we at least use the um this
restriction of hosts to get more uh
tractable instances of approximate
counting one particular example here is
counting independent sets so approximate
counting independent sets is hard in
general because decision is hard but if
we have a monotone class of host graphs
that is um not the class of all graphs
uh in this case we actually get an
approximate counting algorithm so there
might actually be hope that this idea of
restricting the host in addition to
restricting the pattern gives us more
possibilities to get efficient
algorithms for approximate Counting okay
however I am out of time thank you very
much for uh watching this video and I
hope I see you at the conference thank
you very much